-Hello, hello, hello.
-Stray, it is appearance
number 19 for you.
-I know.
-It is a record, most ever.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, Jimmy, nine--
I don't show up at
my other real job 19 times.
[ Laughter ]
-19 times.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show
and always being awesome.
-I consider this
like another job, except for I
don't get paid for this one.
-Exactly.
-But it's all good.
I'm happy to see everybody.
That's why I keep coming back.
Best audience
in television, man.
-I got to see --
I got to see you this weekend.
This past weekend, we got
to spend some time together.
We were in Vegas.
-Yeah.
-For Justin Timberlake,
does a charity golf tournament.
And we went for it, yeah.
And it was -- it was a big deal.
And you came out, and there was
a ton of people out there,
athletes playing.
But, you know,
there could only be one winner.
You know what I'm saying?
And, uh...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. There you go.
That's me and Justin.
We won the tournament.
Justin --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Justin Timberlake
and Jimmy Fallon
won the tournament.
-Okay. Okay. Can I speak?
Can I say something?
-Unh-unh.
-First of all, the win --
the win is beyond suspect.
That's all I'm gonna say.
[ Laughter ]
-Beyond.
-What?!
-There's a lot I can say.
We don't have time.
And, two, we were in Vegas.
-Yeah.
-It was 80, 90 degrees.
And you're dressing
like you're in Scotland.
[ Laughter ]
And I literally looked at him,
and I told my partner,
Matthew Stafford, I said,
"Jimmy looks like someone
who's dressed
like he's the invisible man
who wants to be seen.
He's got --
He's got so much on, man."
Why are you -- It's 90.
Why do you have a sweater on?
[ Laughter ]
-That's a stylish man
right there.
-That was a sweaty man
[ Laughter ]
But we had a great time, man.
-Well, you know what it is?
Because I packed,
I flew from New York,
and I picked a couple outfits
that I thought would be cool,
fun to wear.
And then when I get there,
I didn't bring options.
-Well, you know, they got
an app called Weather.
You just look on that sucker,
and you can put it
anywhere in the world.
It'll tell you what the
weather's going to be.
-No one -- No one tells
the champ how to dress, man.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Come on, bud.
You know what I'm sayin'?
[ Laughs ]
-You guys have a lot of
mad golfers out there
for next year.
I will tell you that.
-You bet.
-A lot of them.
-I want to talk to you
about some NFL news here,
because this is big news
in New York.
Aaron Rodgers is coming
to the New York Jets.
-Jets.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Your Eagle fans over there,
going, "Oh, whatever, whatever."
You know, I think that --
I think it's great.
I mean, to me, it shows --
I don't know if they'll get him
for more than one year.
That's the thing.
But they gave up a first round
pick and some other stuff,
but it shows
that they're all in
and they think
they've got a team
who can make a run at it.
-Well, they had a good --
They have a good defense, right?
-They have a great defense.
They have great receivers,
great running back.
They just couldn't score.
I mean,
their quarterback last year,
I think he needs some time
to develop a little bit more.
And I think there's no one
better to learn
from than Aaron Rodgers.
So if you're going to get him
for a year or two,
I think the Jets, they brought
a lot of excitement.
They're going to sell
a lot of season tickets
if they're not already sold out.
But I don't know
if you're going to get him
for more than a year or two.
So good luck.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Do you think he's going
to fit in in New York?
-I don't know if --
I don't know if Aaron Rodgers
and the media...
The media here is kind of like
guilty until proven innocent.
Like, they don't like you.
You have to make them like you.
-Yeah.
-And I think he comes in
already off of darkness --
darkness retreat,
so they're gonna be like,
"You know, this guy..."
-Darkness retreated.
-I think they're gonna
I think they're gonna
probably try to give him
a little bit of benefit
of the doubt.
But they're looking.
-It's tough.
-So it's gonna be interesting
to see how he handles the media
because they can't -- they can't
be tamed here in New York.
They're tough.
-No, you can't tell them
what's up.
-No.
-How about the draft coming up?
Any --
-I'm interested
in the quarterbacks.
Like, who goes --
Does Young go first from Alabama
or does Stroud from Ohio State?
Like, you know, I just like
watching the first few
because every team knows
who they're going to pick.
Pretty much.
-They do.
-But then
they run the clock out.
So they make something
that should take 15 minutes
to get 30 picks
take like four hours.
-So the deals are done.
They know who it is.
-Yeah, for the most part.
And I'm like, "Come on, man.
You know who you're gonna pick.
Hurry up!
I got stuff to do."
-Yeah, but --
but you've been
in that position.
Are you -- Are you nervous?
-I get nervous for these kids.
I was nervous.
-You were?
-Yeah. I was like,
"Do I got to get a real job,
or, you know...?"
[ Laughter ]
"Mom, Dad, I'm home."
-"Yeah, I'm staying!
I'm staying a while," yeah.
-But, yeah, you get nervous
because it's your future.
You don't know, you know,
where you're going to end up.
You don't know.
You're hoping you go somewhere
that works for you
and you fit in.
For me, it was fortunately
enough to come here to New York,
but I was still scared to death
because you had Lawrence Taylor
and I was freaking out
about that, going,
"You have him.
You don't need me."
Plus, it's cold here,
and I was coming from Houston.
I didn't want any part of that.
-Yeah, yeah, exactly.
-I mean, the only thing
I looked forward to
is that we got to play
the Eagles twice a year
so we can kick their butts.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Why -- Why do you --
Why do you start every time --
Every time you come here,
you start with The Roots.
-Because I'm sitting here
talking to you,
and they're staring.
I feel the hate.
[ Laughter ]
I can feel it!
[ Sad tuba ]
[ Laughter ]
-I love --
when you walked out today,
they played the "Rocky" theme.
-Exactly.
That's what I'm talking about.
-Philly.
-Always something with Philly.
But I love you guys, man.
You know what?
You were good for about
four or five sacks a year, so...
-Hey!
[ Laughter ]
-But look at where you've come.
You started off
playing football.
It is now beyond.
You're Michael Strahan now.
You're --
You're a lot of great things.
You have your own skincare line.
-Yeah, man.
-Can we discuss this?
-Well, you had a beard
last time we were here.
-That's correct.
Yeah.
-And, you know --
And now it's gone.
-No, but --
-I like you with it.
It looked good.
-You did? Really?
You think I should grow it back?
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
I had a little phase.
I had a phase.
-Yeah, it was good.
-I had a phase.
But now I can use
more of your product.
-Yeah.
-When you have a beard,
there's less face.
-But when you have a beard,
you know, now you --
the beard oil.
-Yeah.
-Use it on your cuticles,
if your cuticles are bad.
But now I think
what you're gonna need,
you're gonna need this --
Where is it at?
The beard wash --
face and beard wash.
But it's a face wash.
-Okay.
I could use that.
-You can use that.
And then you need the face
and neck moisturizer.
Keep your skin soft
and supple.
But any other time,
since you're shaving now,
this shave lotion, this one,
you know,
the NewBeauty Award 2023.
So they chose this
as the Best Shave Gel Cream
out of over 10,000 products.
-Come on, Michael Strahan.
Come on.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Why?
-You know what?
Honestly, it really works.
And I love it
because it's clear.
So when I put it on, I can see
the outline of my beard
and whatever I'm gonna do.
I don't make any mistakes
and miss lines
and different things like that.
And then for you now,
since you're gonna be
shaving it clean,
post-shave balm.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Post-shave balm?
-Yeah. Nice and --
I mean, your skin
looks great already.
-Yeah. Well, let me just...
Does it have a smell to it?
-No.
-No, it doesn't.
-That's the thing.
Because, you know --
because you got --
I learned all these
different things
when we were working on this,
but you don't want
to put too many smells
because smells are subjective.
Somebody likes it or not.
So if you kind of keep things
somewhat neutral,
you give yourself, you know,
more people who may
like your product.
-Dude, you're crushing it, bud.
-I'm trying, man.
-I know you're at Target now,
too.
-Yeah, with Target.com.
-That's massive.
-We're at Amazon, CVS,
Rite Aid,
and MichaelStrahanSkin.com,
so...
-MichaelStrahanSkin.com.
-Yeah.
-Target.com.
Michael Strahan, everybody!
Michael and I
are doing something fun
and sporty after the break.
Stick around.